ce n'est pas une coïncidence si la ville
de shanghai apparaître façon si
grandiose dans ce cas est fort
pas plus qu'il faille s'étonner de voir
une scène se dérouler au casino de macao
la recette est vieille si vous voulez
que les gens se déplacent parler d'eux
mais ce que vous ne savez peut-être pas
c'est pour arriver à diffuser leurs
films en chine les producteurs de james
bond ont dû couper la scène où un agent
chinoise fait abattre et changer le
scénario qui parlait de prostitution
dans le pays hollywood ne veut plus
mettre à dos ce marché gigantesque de
quatre milliards et demi de dollars
américains pour la première fois de
l'histoire les recettes au box office en
chaîne ont même surpassé celle des états
unis au mois de février le réalisateur
du film hors cas cela vous candidement
il faut se soumettre aux exigences du
bureau chinois de la censure si l'on
veut qu'une production soit diffusé dans
le pays oubliées donc les films
controversée sur le régime communiste et
parler en bien de la chine devient ainsi
le mot d'ordre à hollywood si l'on veut
percer la grande muraille
plusieurs joueurs comme disney l'ont
compris et vont même jusqu'à soumettre
leurs scénarios au bureau de la censure
avant même de commencer la production
comme ce fut le cas pour kung fu panda
iii un changement de cap qui influencera
les fils que l'on fait révèle le
réalisateur
à preuve les comédies américaines ne
fonctionne pas très bien dans l'empiré
du milieu
elles sont dorénavant déclin à hollywood
et l'opération charme ne s'arrête pas là
seuls 34 films étrangers peuvent être
diffusés en chine chaque année pour
faire partie de cette sélection
les acteurs commencent à défiler et à
déclarer leur amour pour le pays la
culture la nourriture chinoise
alors faut-il se surprendre de ce
changement tendance pas vraiment disent
les analystes
faire de l'argent a toujours été une
question de vie ou de mort pour la
plupart des scénarios à hollywood
s'adapter pour règles de censure en
chine ne devient donc qu'une autre façon
d'empêcher encore plus ici yvan côté
radio canada mais qu'un